merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de la
transition énergétique madame la
ministre depuis plusieurs jours nous
avons tout entendu concernant votre
appel à la sobriété énergétique comme la
nécessité de porter des cols roulés
plutôt que d'allumer le chauffage si
cela en fait rire certains sachez que ce
n'est pas le cas de 30 % de
consommateurs dépendant d'une énergie au
fioul et au bois oui madame la Première
ministre a précisé dernièrement que le
chèque exceptionnel a laissé tendre aux
personnes se chauffant à ces énergies
pouvant aller jusqu'à 200 euros pour les
foyers les plus modestes après avoir été
oubliés tout ce temps et même si cette
aide va quelque peu soulager certains
foyers l'accompagnement de ces ménages
reste encore insuffisant en quoi en
est-il de l'accompagnement des 27000
communes qui ne sont pas raccordés au
gaz naturel lorsque l'on pense que le
prix des granules de bois à tripler
passant de 5 euros les 15 kg après ce
que 15 euros sur certains territoires
comme en Seine-et-Marne ont peut
imaginer à quel point ces 200 euros
d'aide et seulement pour certains sont
une goutte d'eau dans un océan
2200 euros l'année pour se chauffer
voilà ce quoi et confrontés les Français
madame la ministre de nombreux citoyens
associations vous ont interpellé sur ce
sujet depuis plusieurs années votre
gouvernement a poussé les consommateurs
à passer au bois et au granules pour se
chauffer désormais en plus de cette
hausse exorbitante des prix ils sont
rationnés quand allez-vous étendre le
bouclier tarifaire au chauffage au bois
granules et au fioul vous attendez des
Français un effort collectif mais cet
effort ne pourra être fourni sans
contrepartie sachez que la solidarité ne
s'obtient jamais en laissant les
citoyens sur le bord du chemin